hello and welcome to this video on
playing Rilke here with white I one day
I've got a ton of games against them
probably some sort of blitz match maybe
okay old sim um played a Reggie opening
here
okay maybe should be six now it's the
best move and Bishop he knows that this
is something that is now more commonly
known that we should be sick okay I
expect the pawn that is uncommon
okay
so it was surprised at you that he takes
with this okay now how do we play this I
want to try to play on nose on the dark
squeeze him maybe this is this is
interesting try and form this a night a
form keeping the center entirely
flexible it can be interesting so that I
don't have to commit yet to d3 or d4
setup I would like to go and one point
probably deform to fix the pawn down on
c6 but I don't want to do it with this
Bishop on b2 on the board I'd rather
trade first no okay so stop this for the
moment and he still tough for him to
play in c5 okay so um he wants to go Eve
five that's interesting
now this is actually interesting now II
five I have Quincy five doesn't okay
let's do it anyway not even sure if
could see if I would have netted all
that much anyway let's see what he is
doing now okay
threatening now Bishop f6 okay so he
retreats this one
okay I've got leaf I've covered so any
97 we would trade and I would see five
at the end I wonder would love to make
sure that he's not playing that he is
not playing a five this is an
interesting move intending before and
then before a three and stop the pawn
forever basically
okay now it's a five move that I am
concerned about probably not I can
actually double immediately here that's
interesting if I'm if I've got the the
rooks
doubled on the C file there is Bishop 65
immediately as a threat yeah what they
can't stop it but still have useful
moves here and now when just taking it
as an advantage but is there anything
better night before no probably not
I wonder if dropping back to c5 is
something that is useful you know than
85 okay I'm going to take his position
is of course entirely passive but it is
very solid still he should probably yes
that's a good decision
he's he now has a five still available
very and it is very important that he's
got this one otherwise I would have
played rukka c5
now that's it's actually actually
completely fine for him he's got a five
a four and will take on b3 yeah they're
not very very nicely defended by I'm
lucky I mean it really looked it looked
rotten and I didn't get anything he
should have played a photo I think not a
big deal but I think he should have
played it when there was still this this
easy option
King f2 I could have played it for maybe
but ultimately I need thank you
I need the king on c3 efficiency - he's
doing a good job here in defending this
position really
before it's probably equal we might take
then hmm he might take it I know doesn't
work I mean it might work but it doesn't
give him an advantage
Roxy talking c2 Bishop f5 maybe I can
even go eform Eve for and then G for
yeah I can do that
okay so I got to see farm got that under
control
you cannot invade them it is going to be
really difficult to open the position
okay is so how do we do that that is
saddest I just that is okay
main problem is that have absolutely no
time seconds
I didn't didn't see that mouth Eric
didn't see it at all
cannot coefficient it Joe
aha no what the heck i'm blundering the
friggin bishop oh my god and he can take
it I lose this freaking game this is
insane
now you just have it can never ever lose
this position no ma this must be really
excellent for white Oh Kate you have the
time management of course but still if
hive is probably not right I'm surprised
that the engine just gives me 0.4 I was
thinking that must be a clear advantage
with the with black beans stuck to g6
and yeah I know he's got the H pawn but
still I cannot believe that this is just
a small edge and yeah now you defended
as well and then of course I made a
couple of really terrible oversights
King King f3 is just a bad move I didn't
see Bishop h5 at all I mean of course
this I shouldn't lose but by now and I
lost control
yeah I kind of knew that taking is not
great but I couldn't couldn't figure it
out g6 is still a draw hmm how is the
drawing line takes king he won look g3
back then I have to stop the plaza to
draw okay yeah probably and have to not
play f5 again I didn't I didn't have
that much time to try to find the best
continuation okay the computer likes to
take then f4
and probably time that better layer it's
a little bit of better timing yeah I can
take with the F pawn mmm this is better
really now that is a way forward and is
ending I just want to find out how I can
what the objective way of playing is we
call them in white is obviously quite
substantially better with b5 and g6 and
but wasn't easy to do I mean I had no
time of course but so yeah he defended
this nice diamond exposition basically
sucked the whole time it was just yeah I
had to defend this the whole time
I really hate to lose the game because I
liked I liked how I can maintain the
pressure here does this was I think I
was happy with this it's part of the
game okay this was wrong okay the the it
is essential that he's got to look see
checks yeah this is just clearly better
yeah when I get this to a5 and I
maintain the pressure there but this I
had underestimated know he gets a 5
it's of course a gross error but like
not playing a 4 I mean this is just
really bad I don't think I don't think
he's better as the engine suggests but
he should definitely play a form a form
before a3 rooks III never had time to
believe that black can be better in
anyway you three why is that better for
back
so it is better food like okay I cannot
take because of c-5 mmm so this one yeah
okay that is better for like I still
wonder why I'm that is better for like
85 I got the sequel yeah maybe maybe so
maybe I have to defend defend
differently here hmm
it's quite remarkable but when this
bishop looks bad
but this is not great either I take some
time I can improve that but it takes
time you know the way it went
I am they never played a form I was
ready to answer a phone with before and
now I can try for a little something but
no Jim he never he can now make a draw
by taking and taking everything that
would be possible but he went you
allowed this one may force terrible I
mean just it's not good move
Bishop f5
okay
okay okay I take it back a4 it's not a
bad move but you have to play Bishop f5
I mean if you do this and now play
Bishop f5 playing it's fine you know you
have to have to trade this off simply in
such a situation to have c4 and not
suffer with the bad bishop but after
that I'm better but then let's screw it
up
that was interesting it's really
interesting that I mean I'm so feeling
bad for losing the game because it's
just like you're better the whole time
and in some way now okay I wasn't better
Here I am but that looks he takes b8
something that has should have seen
earlier I recognized once it happened
that a half times I don't have time to
play to do anything against a5 a4 it was
just too late I recognized a too late
okay thanks for watching